for any Italy has become the biggest
threat to the eurozone why is this well
so we're gonna tell you in this video
[Applause]
[Music]
the cradle of the West the place of
pastor Pete saurons popular coffee
making techniques like the cappuccino
ristretto and espresso it's all in Italy
but in addition to this Italy has become
quite a headache for Europe's leaders no
wonder I mean we're talking about a
giant of the could turn into a true
Titanic
[Music]
we're talking about an economic and
financial crisis that could make
Greece's crisis look like child's play
see Italy currently has the eighth
largest economy in the world but this
country isn't growing its banking system
has loads of problems and its government
is hugely in debt
in fact Italy's public debt already
surpasses a hundred and thirty percent
of its GDP which means that even though
it has the fourth largest economy in the
European Union after Germany the United
Kingdom and France it also has the
largest public debt stock this amounts
to more than 2.5 trillion dollars the
Italian public debt folks is twice the
size of the entire Mexican economy and
almost four times the size of the Swiss
economy and that's if you didn't figure
out is a lot of money
[Music]
that the problem doesn't even begin to
end there the Italian economy is hardly
growing in fact it hasn't managed to get
back to its pre 2008 crisis levels
unemployment it surpasses 10 percent and
youth unemployment lies it around 40
percent to all of this we need to add
the fact that year after year public
debt continues to rise and it won't stop
growing the country has a very big
population with an aging problem and
above all the European Central Bank
which in recent years has been Italy's
largest public debt purchaser could soon
stop doing that European Central Bank
says its massive bond-buying program
will likely end in December all of that
said we can easily understand news like
this
Italy is pushing Europe to the brink of
another economic crisis the Italian
crisis that is making the EU tremble
worsens alright there's something you
might now be wondering well yes Simon I
get it but this is hardly new Italy's
been a problem for ages why we
spotlighting it now well I'm gonna tell
you
new government a step back after months
of uncertainty a new government finally
gained power in June of 2018 and we're
not talking about just any government
led by the new prime minister Giuseppe
Conte we're talking about a government
formed by the euro skeptic an anti
system movement five stars and by La
Liga an extremely far right-wing party
this new coalition arrived with a very
clear idea in mind
Italy's sovereignty would again be in
Rome and not in Brussels which in most
cases we don't mean anything except a
higher expenditure
well the fact is that as you know the
countries that belong to the euro zone
that is those that share the same
currency agree on certain goals with the
European authorities as well as on some
maximum public deficit levels and on a
path that these deficits have to follow
over the years all of this is done to
maintain their stability and solvency
and thus reduce the risk of crisis well
the new Italian government does not like
this one yet deficit path I mean come on
oh you're not gonna tell me how to spend
my money Europe and this is more or less
what the new government must have
thought because one of the first things
they did was present a budget proposal
in September for a public deficit that
is substantially larger than the one
they committed to in Brussels and that
is when the earthquake happens
Italy defies the European Union and
increases their deficit 2.4 percent of
GDP a new government wanting to spend
money that listen he's got a public debt
problem and now they want to ask for a
higher debt well seeing is believing
because folks 2.4 percent might sound
low but if we take the fact that the
Italian economy is forecasted to not
grow more than 1 percent in the upcoming
years into account then things really do
change because that 2.4 percent now
means that with every year that passes
Italy will become less solvent that is
it will be even less able to pay off its
debts so do you know what came of this
dialogue between the New Year skeptic
government and Brussels well check it
out
since Jersey pecan tez new government
orientation was exposed the 10-year
Italian bonds profitability soared by
more than 90 percent that is investors
now understand that there's a very high
risk and therefore they require a higher
profitability if they're gonna lend
their money obviously this means that
every time the Italian government issues
debt it has to include higher interest
this means that up to the year 2020
Italy will have to face debt maturities
of almost 600 million dollars in amounts
that of course it'll have to request
again from the markets along with the
deficits that it has accumulated until
then this amounts to more than 700
billion dollars which is an insane
number
well if investors ask for more
profitability interest will be higher
and so with the public deficit and if in
addition the European Central Bank stops
buying debt it could mean even higher
interest rates to the point that this
spiral could put the Italian government
on the ropes and then its banks as
thought they own a good part of Italy's
debt also it doesn't really seem likely
that they will be able to withstand a
new recession italy's banks stumble into
a new crisis and of course that's not
all italy isn't greece its huge size
could mean the spread of their financial
crisis throughout the entire eurozone
that's why the new Italian government's
policies have led just so much concern
Italy is a time bomb that could simply
explode at any moment that's why it
doesn't seem likely that the European
Central Bank will stop funding the party
the only reason Italy isn't already
rated junk is because the ratings
agencies assume the ECB will step in to
prevent a default in that sense Italian
bonds are actually German bonds John
Rubino the question now is well how long
can this situation lost but now that we
know what's happening the question that
remains is how did we get to this point
well listen up
[Music]
the origin of the problem also long ago
we dedicated a video to how Italy
arrived at the situation we can
basically summarize it as a lack of
competitiveness for years Italian
politicians really didn't care about the
economy while the world changed full
speed Italy punished companies with
extremely high taxes and lots of
regulations and that's not all the state
kept hiring more and more officials and
spending money without really caring
about the results for example only one
in five young Italians gets a university
degree a rate that's almost half of the
OECD average and of course if you aren't
educating your youth and forget about
being competitive well what else can you
expect if that weren't enough by
adopting the euro Italian politicians
can no longer use one of their favourite
tricks devaluing the currency so this
folks this is what explains the dark
news that we occasionally see in the
media as you can probably see the
situation that's all rather complicated
and here a visual politic we're gonna
try and keep up with all the events but
now it's your turn do you think that the
Italian government should break with
Brussels well leave your answer in the
comments below as well as in this survey
and I really hope you enjoyed this video
please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos also don't forget to
check out our friends at the reconsider
Media podcast they provided the vocals
in this episode that were not mine and
also this channel it's possible because
of patreon and our patrons on that
platform please do consider joining them
and supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage as always
I'll see you in the next
[Music]